Alright, talk me through it.
>> Okay, so I'm going to say that I think I know the answers for this
one. And let's start with the first one.
So R1 equals minus R2, which you'll notice
they're equal and opposite. And in fact if you add them up, that is you sum
them you end up with zero. So I'm
going to say that's a zero sum stochastic game.
>> Nice.
>> For two, basically you're saying that for all intends
and purposes, there's only one agent. Which just makes it
a regular Markov decision process.
>> Yeah. So isn't that interesting? That
just by the other player irrelevant, then
that's what an MDP is. It's like a game where the other players are irrelevant.
>> Yeah, which, both of my children are like that.
But okay, I think that's pretty cool. And in fact, I'd
be right in saying that R2 doesn't have to equal
to zero. As long as it just equals to some constant.
>> Yeah, that's, I mean, constant. Actually, depending on
how you think about it, it could be, we could just ignore
the whole R2 thing and just say that. As far as the
first player is concerned, since the second player really has no impact
on anything. It doesn't matter. But the reason I put that in
is I got kind of scared that like. I feel like if I
lived my life and knew that my actions effected the state and
my rewards, but they were also effecting the rewards of somebody who
didn't matter. Like I feel like that would actually still have an influence
on me. Sure, but then the way you get around that is
you would say, well, your R1 is actually equal to your R2.
>> Oh.
>> [CROSSTALK] It would somehow [UNKNOWN].
>> So, so if I had gone like that, wouldn't
that be the case then that we're saying? Oh yeah,
I see. That the second player is irrelevant, but the
reward, but the first player may be relevant to both.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, okay, yeah I like that a little bit better. Yeah,
I mean, once again, it all boils down to changing the rewards. Okay,
and so given A and B, I know the answer to
three must be C, unless you're tricking me, and it could be
A or B again. And which I suppose you could have
done, you didn't say they were mutually exclusive. So let me actually
argue why it would be C? Well there is only one
state and since you're in a stochastic game and you're going to
be continually doing this. It means that you're basically doing the same
game over and over and over again, so it's a repeated game.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah so in particular the actions impact the rewards,
but they're not going to impact the transitions
because you're always just going to back to
where you were. The discount factor plays the
role of, of decided when the game's going
to end, stochastically. And, so yeah, it's exactly
a repeated game, this is the one I
feel most comfortable about because this really does
recover that same model we've been talking about.
>> I like it.
>> Cool! Now, given that we actually are now
in a model that generalizes MDPs, it would be
nice if we can generalize some of the things
that we did with MDPs, like Q learning and
value iteration to this, this more general setting.
So, that's what we're going to try next.
>> Cool.